This video is sponsored by Wolf thunder,
play war thunder for free and get a premium aircraft Croft or ship into
three-day accounts. Upgrade as a bonus,
it's available on PCPs for an X-Box one more on them in a bit.
He was a man born into the world to shake the nations. The scourge of all lands,
who in some way,
terrified all mankind by the dreadful rumors noised abroad
concerning him. That's is a contemporary description of a tiller.
The man who transforms the Huns from a gathering of nomadic tribes into an
empire that dominated the world with an unsurpassed speed and fierceness.
They say that the flame, which burns twice as bright burns, half as long,
and this is an apt metaphor for the Hanuk empire.
They seemingly appeared out of nowhere and almost immediately it became a force
to be reckoned with defeating all the nations that stood in their way.
Even the Roman empire learns to fear artilleryman the cold flagellum
day or of a scourge of God,
but then Siller died and the Hunter can buy collapsed just as fast as it had
sprung to life, even.
So their impact was still felt as the Hanuk invasions caused a period of great
migrations where Germanic tribes headed out West to escape the wrath of
the Huns, the golfs, the vandals, the Lombards, the Franks,
the Anglo Saxons them and many more packed up and settled new
lands where their descendants can still be found today. But of course,
most of these lands already belongs to the Romans who would not give them up
without a fight.
The Wars between these two sides directly led to the fall of the Western Roman
empire.
It becomes evidence that the Hanukkah invasions under a tiller changed the
landscape of the worlds.
Forever.
But tell us the year of birth is one big question.
Mark dates have been suggested that range from the late fourth century to the
early fifth century, Ady based on the events in his life.
Some scholars believed that 395 AED is the most probable birth. Yeah.
While others think the 406 80 is more likely.
So it could have been one or the other,
or it could have just been something in between. We just don't know the same.
Uncertainty extends to a Telus people, the Huns,
they were a warrior nomadic nation.
So they didn't really leave behind texts or monuments or cities,
which we could study to understand that culture and the Western historical
record,
they simply appeared toward the end of the fourth century when they decided to
cross the vulgar river and expand into Eastern and central Europe,
historians have debated their origin and even the language that they spoke,
but they don't know anything with absolute certainty.
One popular idea suggests some kind of link with an early animatic people
originating in Mongolia and attested in ancient Chinese sources.
The Zhang knew they had lived in the region as early as the third century BC and
had gone to war against the Chinese hand dynasty for 200 years before
eventually suffering a decisive defeat.
Some argue that the Shaun knew where in fact,
the hums while others believes there was at least some continuity between the
tribes. But again, always stress that this is just speculation.
When it comes to a tiller himself, we find a scarcity of reliable sources.
One major contribution was PRISCUS of Pentium,
a Roman diplomat and historian who was not only alive during the hums rain,
but it's actually met a tiller as part of a diplomatic mission to his court.
Presbycusis work did not survive in its entirety,
but it was quoted by later historians such as Jordanians and CALSEIA Doris.
Therefore we do have fragments of it included in other texts that did survive.
One juicy beds provided by PRISCUS is a description of a tiller.
He was haughty in his walk, rolling his eyes, his, uh, and the, the, so the,
the power of his proud spirits appears in the movement of his body.
He was indeed a lover of war yet restrained in action, mighty in council,
gracious to supplicants and lenient to those who once received into his
protection. He is short of stature with a broad chest and a large head.
His eyes were small, his beard thin and sprinkled with gray.
And he had a flat nose and a swarthy complexion showing the evidences of his
origin.
And though his temper was such that he always had great self-confidence yet his
assurance was increased by finding the sword of Mars,
always esteemed sacred among the Kings of the time.
Yes.
And mom's first came to Europe. They were not unified as a single force.
They were still made up of loosely affiliated clans that each has their own
King, their first major conquest,
where the Allan so well followed by plenty of other small and obscure tribes
that had the misfortune of being in the weight.
As the Huns made advances into Europe,
they began encountering Gothic nations like the thingy and GRU sung guy.
These two proved no match for the invading hordes and they were forced to
retreat further to the West.
It was only a matter of time before they eventually ran into Roman territory.
I'm speaking of the Romans, we should make a quick mention of their situation.
By this point, the power of the Roman empire was fading.
It was no longer the juggernaut that it used to be holding dominion over most of
Europe and parts of Asia and Africa.
It had unofficially been divided into the Western and Eastern Roman empire,
meaning that's. It had two political administrations, two emperors,
and two capitals. The Eastern Roman also known as the Byzantine empire,
which was headquartered at Constantinople while the Western Roman empire no
longer used Rome as its seat of power, but rather media Lanham,
AKA Milan.
It should be pointed out that this division between Eastern West was done
retroactively by modern scholars to create a more evident distinction between
the two political entities.
Romans from that time would have still considered themselves simply citizens of
a single empire. The division was also done with the benefit of hindsight.
Since historians knew that the Western Roman empire would collapse completely in
the late fifth century while the Byzantine embalm,
which is another time applied retroactively, by the way,
would last for another thousand years. Anyway,
the Gulf sought refuge in Roman lands a first Eastern Roman emperor valence
gave them permission to settle, probably looking at them as a cheap Alami.
However,
the lands they were given was not sufficient to hold all the people fleeing the
Huns food shortages, let derives and revolts,
which in 376 blossomed into a fully fledged war.
This was one of many such conflicts between the goths and the Raymonds.
Of course, while all this was going on, the Huns made their own incursions.
They attacked the parts of the Eastern Roman empire that corresponded to Western
Asia, such as Kapha, dosha, and Syria.
They probably also tried their luck against the Sasanian or Neo Persian empire,
but encountered a red defeat and driven back into Europe. At times,
the hums were employed as mercenaries by the Romans to fight the goths.
One notable example was in 406,
a D when King [inaudible] led an army of Ostrogoths to invade Italy,
the Romans use tons Allen's and golfs as mercenaries to help them win the war
over the following decades, the Romans and the Huns had an uneasy Alliance,
although both sides, occasionally brokers and attacks one another,
something more important happened though,
the Hulus became a United force under a man named Ruga or sometimes regalia.
He either ruled alone a Supreme King aided by his brother, Octa,
or they were code rulers and each brother held dominion over half of that
territory either way. Oxon was the first to die around 438 D.
So at least for a while,
Ruger was the sole ruler of the Huns Briga has another brother.
And his name was Mungiu because he had two sons, beta and Attila.
We're not sure if we got lacked any sons visit zone or how the Ascension process
works, but when we're in good died in 434,
a D his two nephews became the new rulers of the Huns.
And if you are going to become the ruler of your own, well,
let me tell you about today's sponsor war thunder or thunder is a realistic free
to play military vehicle combat game.
It's available on PC PS4 and Xbox one,
but you only need one of those to play. There's also no need to purchase year,
just download and get started in this game.
There are over 1,500 historically accurately.
It's all the way from the 1920s to the 1990s. And they're all carefully built,
incredibly detailed,
and you can see that all the physics in the game has really been sweated over.
It's really very, very good plus super immersive sound.
So that's also cool play with a good pair of headphones. And look,
you can also just jump in for a quick arcade game.
If you don't have much time last me, or you can play realistic,
you can go for the more challenging tactical stuff, or if you're hardcore,
there's always simulator, but yeah,
I've never played that because I don't like getting my whipped over and over
again.
So join us on the battlefield for free using the link below doing that supports
this show,
and you also get a free premium tank ship or at Crofts in three days of premium
time, as a bonus for registering, let's get back to today's video.
Bleeding.
And the teller. We're now in charge of the lens of the hums,
which were steadily growing to become quite the empire. In fact,
by the time until it died, the Hanuk empire rivaled, the Roman one in size,
as far as power dynamics between him and his brother.
We're not entirely sure it is possible that they had an arrangement similar to
Ruger and are where each sibling held dominion over half the empire.
But it is also possible that the Huns regarded only one of them was their
Supreme, chief Tang, whatever the relationship was.
It continued for 11 years until bleed his death around 445 eight deep
those circumstances. It won't surprise you to discover also somewhat uncertain.
Although the classic sources claim that Attila killed his brother to assume sole
control of the hunts we turned to PRISCUS again,
who Rose to those bleeder King of the Huns was assassinated as a result of the
plots of his brother, a tiller,
but we are getting ahead of ourselves just a bit.
And let's start with the beginning of a Tiller's rain.
The first issue that needed to be dealt with where the Romans at the time,
Rome was relatively neutral with the hands under Ruger,
but they had to consider that his nephews might have other ideas.
The Romans were already paying the hunters tribute, and as it turns out,
they were willing to pay quite a bit more in exchange for peace in 435,
the two sides signs, the treaty of Margus,
which was quite favorable to the Huns. The remanent bought would pay.
Then they fixed annual tribute of 700 pounds of gold,
which was double what they were paying before. They also vowed to return on it,
refugees and devoid entering alliances with enemies of the Huns.
This was a pretty sweet deal for,
until it was over the moment he saw no conflict with the Romans. Instead,
he thought he would invade Persia again and try to take down the sustainer and
bar, hoping to succeed where his predecessors had failed.
We don't have solid sources on this part of his reign since the Romans weren't
involved,
but suffice to say that the teller was defeated and forced to retreat back to
Europe, that his first dog, it was good into Hawk King of burgundy.
This King also known as Gunther or Ghana became a character in popular legends
and appears in both the Nordic collection of poems called poetic Edda and the
dramatic song of nibbling, the legendary version of King Goodhart,
who was slain and basle in 437 by Essilor himself,
the historical one it's far less likely.
The Romans were the primary enemies of the begun Indians.
While the hun served as auxiliary mercenaries pad that treaty the begun scions
had crossed into Roman goal and invaded the province of Belgium prenup.
Naturally the Romans fought back and with the help of the Huns defeated that bow
in battle afterwards,
they continued that push and destroyed the kingdom of burgundy.
The man in charge of the army. It was Flavius ATS,
powerful and influential general.
During the last days of the Western Roman empire, because of this,
he was nicknamed the last of the Romans and historian.
Edward Gibbon described him as being universally celebrated as the terror of the
barbarians and the support of the Republic.
We highlight him now because he will play a more important role a bit later on.
Of course,
everyone knew that the peace treaty between the two powers would not last long
in 441,
the hunters crossed the Danube and attacked the Eastern Roman empire plundering.
The provinces of [inaudible] obviously this maintenance,
the treaty of Maga, but the hungs claimed the Romans actually broke it first,
whether or not this was true or merely an excuse to loot and pillage.
We can't say the timing was somewhat suspicious as the hums designed to do its
act right after emperor. Theodosius the secondary located the garrisons,
defending that border to send them off, to fight the vandals in Africa,
the most likely explanation was simply there's a Telus or a weakness,
and he decided to exploit it. And he was quite successful in that regards,
the hung spillage,
several Roman cities and even raised a few to the grounds like 443 Theodosius
was ready to sign a new treaty, even more beneficial to the Huns.
This satisfied Attila who once again retreated into the heart of his empire so
that some historians argue that someone documented emergency might have
appeared, which required until his attention.
Otherwise he would have had no reason to stop the invasion since his army had
the clear advantage.
This is also the points where bleeder died and the tiller became sole chief tain
of the Huns. We can only speculate over a possible connection between these two,
whether or not the Romans actually paid their attributors on certain.
It is probable that they simply stalled for a few years,
trying to strengthen their defenses for the inevitable time when the Hung's
invaded. Again,
this happens in 447 when Attila led his army into the Eastern Roman empire
again, and ravaged all of the provinces located in the Balkans.
One contemporary souls claims that the hunters captured over a hundred cities
going all the way to the monopoly in Greece, before turning back.
These might've been necessary sacrifices as the Romans concluded that they
needed to gather all of their forces into one powerful army,
instead of letting them die bit by bit trying to defend each city.
The invasion culminated in the battle of Hooters and Deisha.
Repentances near the modern day river VIT in Bulgaria,
the Romans who were led by on a guest cruise,
who found the position of Magister militant,
the highest military rank in the empire at the time on a guest close,
died in battle. And the Romans were defeated by the Huns,
but not without causing some serious casualties.
After this Attila had his eyes set on the grandest prize possible
Constantinople of the capital of the Eastern Roman empire. However,
the famed walls of Constantinople,
plus Roman reinforcements arriving from Asia minor plus all the losses of the
Hunter sustained in the battle of the uterus mentioned that Attila was not
strong enough to take the city. He realized this, so he didn't even try.
Instead. He signed a new peace treaty. This time,
the tribute paid to a tiller was triple what it was first 2,100 pounds of
gold each year. Plus a number of other concessions.
Another conflict ended the Hung's return to the great Hungarian Plains,
but only long enough to regain their strength and numbers before marching out
for wall. Once more, they sat out again in 450,
but this time they did not attack the Eastern Roman empire,
instead of focused his attention on its Western counterparts.
This was a somewhat surprising decision Attila,
not one to conquer Constantinople anymore.
Emperor Theodosius died that same year,
and he was followed on the throne by Marcien.
The latter used to be a general and took a markedly different approach to
dealing with the Hunzas.
He immediately ended the treaty between them and stopped all payments.
Not that he needed one,
but this would have been the perfect justification for a Tila to attack the
Eastern Roman empire once more.
But he did not deviate from his invasion plans of the West.
According to a story in Jordanians,
the tiller wanted to go that way because he also intended to attack the
Visigoths not just the Romans.
He may or may not have been doing this at the request of gay Sarek King of the
vandals who showered the leader of the hunters with gifts and incited him
against Thea Doric King of the Visigoths for his own personal revenge
until his expressed reason for invading the Western Roman empire was a strange
and unique one emperor in the West was Valentini on the set.
He had a sister named honoria who was engaged to marry a Senator named
basses hacky Lunis. This marriage had been arranged by her brother,
but honoria had no desire to go through with it.
So of all the people in the world, she sought out help from Attila, the hun,
sending him a note and a ring.
Now we don't know what was written in the notes and what kind of help honoria
was expecting,
but Attila chose to interpret her proposal as an offer of marriage.
Not only that, but he felt he was do you half the Western Roman empire,
his dowry even sent a messenger to Valentini and to confirm that the proposal
had been legitimate and the Tila would come to claim what was his it's doubtful
that Tila cares about the marriage? Well,
there's he actually expected the Roman emperor to just handover half of his
empire.
This was most likely just another convenient excuse for him to wage a bit of war
in 451 Atilla invaded Roman gold.
Jordyn's claims that his army numbered half a million men,
but modern historians place it lower at around 200,000 men, either way.
It was eight,
the middle force that quickly snorted all of those who stood in its way.
So he's like tree air in that's captured and plundered almost with no
opposition. You know, the old saying the enemy of my enemy is my friends. Well,
that is how the Romans felt as well because Valentina and requested the help of
the nearby Gothic factions,
he would have almost certainly been fighting the Roman empire.
Were it not for the hunts?
He sends an ambassador with a message bravest of nations.
It is the policy of prudence for us to unite against the Lord of the earth,
who wishes to enslave the whole world. He requires no just cause for battle,
but supposes, whatever he does is right.
He measures his ambition by his might license,
satisfies his pride despite his law and writing shows himself and enemy to
nature.
And thus he who clearly is the common foe of each deserves the hatred of all
the Franks, the Saxons, the Burgundians, the islands,
and especially the Visigoths led by King Theodore Eric,
or realize that they were just as much in danger from the Huns as the Romans
were. So they agreed to forming the lines to fight a teller and his army.
[Inaudible].
Well, the challenge against the Huns was Flavius ATS.
The same commander who wants, fought along side them against the Burgundians.
He led a coalition of nations and met the Huns of the battle of Shalom.
Also known as the battle of Catalunian fields on June the 20th 451,
a deep up to that point.
This had been one of the bloodiest military conflicts in history as eye
witnesses reported the planes filling up with thousands of bodies piles on top
of one another. They also said that within the hunting camp,
Attila had made a massive funeral path for himself and was prepared to throw
himself on it, to burn alive rather than be captured.
Historians have varied opinions on the outcome of this conflict and its
historical impact,
but most would agree that the Romans in the Visigoth has won the battle.
Although with heavy casualties,
Kings Theodora fell in battle and his son swordsmens wanted to invade the camp
and wipe out the hums once. And for all,
they probably could have done it to where it not for atheists actually
intervening on behalf of a tiller and convincing the young thorugh, Siemens,
this as the new King of the Visigoth scene needed to return to that capital of,
to lose and to consolidate his power against his plotting brothers.
Why would ATS do such a thing though,
when he had an opportunity to rid himself of the Huns?
Well that's because a fear that the Visigoths had the potential to turn into an
even more dangerous foe when he was a lot closer to his borders,
as long as the tiller was around,
he served as a useful common enemy United the Romans and the golfs.
So tele was able to retrieve,
living to fight another day and fight he did as less than a year had passed
before the Hung's returns to a tax, the Western Roman empire. Again,
this time they went straight into Italy, clearly intends on pillaging,
the most significant Roman sediments, the city of Akron layer,
India to the West of it being almost completely raised the grounds afterwards,
the Huns continued into the province of Benicia,
where they plundered more sediments. According to tradition,
this led to the founding of the city of Venice.
It was settled by refugees who left other cities in order to escape the Huns.
And they correctly surmised that Attila's cavalry's would not follow them into
the lagoon that encloses Venice, without a Gothic muscle,
the Romans were not capable of stopping a tiller.
Eventually the emperor sent multiple envoys to try and secure a piece with the
Huns. And one of them was Pope Leo.
The first contemporary sources gave Leo the credit for convincing Attila to turn
back after having been impressed with Leo's words and his piety,
the exact details of that meeting are known,
but modern historians give more practical reasons for a Tiller's withdrawal,
such as a lack of resources due to a famine disease,
which spread among his soldiers and the fact that an army from the Eastern Roman
empire crossed the Danube and launched a counter attack on hunt settlements,
whatever the reason that's Ella would have surely invaded once more given the
opportunity. However, his life came to an end in 453,
a D while celebrating his marriage to a new wife named IL Dico.
According to ancient historian.
PRISCUS the leader of the Huns fell on his bed in a drunken stupor with his head
tilted back.
And he choked on his own blood either from a burst blood vessel or from a very
powerful nosebleed alternative hypothesis has been put forward,
such as elder go assassinating him,
or until her dying of internal bleeding caused by excessive drinking in morning,
all the hum soldiers cut their long hair and slashed that SHEEX so that the
greatest of all warriors should be mourned,
not with tears or the wailing of women, but with the blood of men,
according to their traditions,
it was really important for that chief teen's burial place to be anonymous.
Of course, they never had a chief Dame greater than the Tila.
So he was placed inside three coffins,
a gold one inside a silver one inside an odd one.
The coffin was then buried in a river bed and the people who did it were killed
so that there would be nobody left alive,
who knew where the final resting place of Attila the hun.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Do not forget to subscribe brand new videos,
just like this a couple of times a week.
So click that subscribe button below and thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].